champion in chess history yeah has  anyone answered derek hasbro yeah we  have actually it's like you read my  my spreadsheet in front of me and yeah  shokan says that uh for them the best  chess champion is kasparov he was  competing with karpov during the big  changes in the soviet union and the  whole world and for many people he's not  only a talented chess player but an  agent of change he is still a fighter  for dramatic democracy and freedom aha  meanwhile sorry there ivanka but we have  seen hans niemann i think he was cursing  himself a moment ago he was talking to  himself  slapping his face he has just blundered  a pawn  we were praising the  drama london system  and the opening actually worked out very  well for white until just two moves ago  or three moves ago when he made a  miscalculation and  look how much he's suffering now look  how much  kind of frustration there is in his face  and